(electronic music)
- Well, now it's time for
tonight's Hashtag Wars.
Eliza Coupe.
- Fully Erect Bizkit.
- Points, points.
Deon.
- Soul Train.
- [Chris] Yes, points, Donald.
- Backstreet Men.
- Points, Eliza.
- They Might Be Giants Fans.
- Yes, points.
Deon.
- Counting Hos.
- [Chris] Points.
Donald.
- Savage Olive Garden.
- Points.
♪ I want to stand with you
♪ On a mountain of pasta
- Jane's Rehab.
- Jane's Rehab, good, points.
Deon.
- Rage Against the
Intel Processor.
- [Chris] Yes, points.
Donald Faison.
- A simple one.
Cypress Phil.
- Yes, points.
Rob.
- Weekend at Bert and Ernie's.
- Yes, points.
Randy.
- Miss Piggy Azalea.
She's got a lot of back
bacon in that trunk.
- Yeah, points.
Yeah, shake that (bleep), Piggy.
Jay.
- Legally Obligated
to Inform You
that I've Moved Into
the Neighborhood Elmo.
- So good, points.
Rob.
- Oscar Pistorius the Grouch.
- (Bleep)
- Thanks.
- [Chris] That would
be a rejected Muppet.
Technically, Oscar doesn't
have any legs either.
All right, points, Randy.
- Jim Henson's naked hand.
- Points, that's a little.
Mitch.
- Unplug it and plug it back in.
- Yeah, that's
what you gotta do,
count to ten, plug it back in.
Bob Odenkirk.
- Make it all one button.
- Yep, points.
Yes, Mitch.
- Tweet a picture of Kim
Kardashian's thoughts.
- Yes, points
(some audience members groan)
Oh, shit.
- It's not that enlightening.
- [Chris] No, that
broke their minds.
- Mike.
- When on Facebook, don't
just like something.
Love something.
- Yeah, points.
Bob.
- Free U2 album, that'll
chase everyone away.
- Dangle.
- Boy Toys for Tots.
- Points.
Travis.
- Partnership for a
Drug-Free Coachella.
- Points, Travis, again.
- Doctors Without Credentials.
- Points.
God damn it, Travis.
- Bend Over and
Make-a-Wish Foundation.
- Points.
Yes, Wiegel.
- Save a Kid, Punch a Puppy.
- Points.
Dangle.
- Race for the Cure
and Depeche Mode.
- Points, points.
Wiegel.
- Inexpensive Mammograms
from a Dude in a Van.
- OK, good.